thank you so much for sitting down with
me today I I love the movie so the first
thing I noticed when we're not looking
at the robot it kind of remind me of the
Boston dynamic robots was that your
inspiration for it absolutely okay so
what was your - was your choice for that
just because like we're entering a new
and interesting realm with this stuff
that's traditionally been very science
fiction is now kind of urging like
coming close on science fact like where
our stuff is very real and could be
something that we're facing in the near
future so we we had the benefit of being
able to look at those stuff that's
actually being done in labs in the world
right now and using it for inspiration
and if you can reference something real
why wouldn't you you make sense I make I
make sense it feels like there was some
inspiration from other classic sci-fi
films can you talk about that and you're
pulling from those and trying to make it
different from those from the previous
inspiration totally like particularly
with or just the film in general yeah oh
yeah I mean like you can't help but be
inspired by everything that you've ever
seen and it's an interesting parallel
with how these AI programs are created
these days like this sort of super
intelligent AI systems get a huge amount
of data they read everything that's on
the internet and then they can learn to
speak a new language or create a
painting or create a piece of motor
directing a film is a weird parallel of
that like you've watched a whole bunch
of movies and that's how you prepare
yourself to be able to make a film and
like those influences we really wear on
our sleeve and something like I am
mother like I'm a child of Ridley Scott
and James Cameron and Steven Spielberg
and all of those those filmmakers sort
of are in the DNA of this you say this
was a film or but to study what it means
to really be good can you elaborate on
that and talk about what you really
meant yeah like it's this parallel
debate that Michael and I were having
about how to become decent parents like
how do you instill right and wrong
within a child and likewise if you're
creating an AI system how do you instill
right and wrong in that AI system and
how do you know what is right and what's
wrong so many of us sort of take for
granted that we're just shooting from
the hip and have a natural instinct for
for how we make these decisions and do
the right thing but that's often based
on religion or it's based on what our
parents just told us to believe or maybe
you've picked up a book and you've
studied some philosophy but no one
really knows where that
tonight sense of right and wrong comes
from and this film was a chance to sort
of explore one character trying to work
out how she felt about something
separate to what she was being told from
the outside world and from the people
that she knew with this in particular
this is your first this is your
directorial debut film can you talk
about anything you learned during the
process that you could you would advise
up-and-coming directors to make sure of
if you can work with Hilary Swank if you
can work with workshop also really good
Clara and Rose are fantastic too I've
been really blessed that like we wrote a
really good script and that was the
thing that interacted like this
incredible caliber of people and I think
really the end product is a reflection
of the caliber of people that
contributed to it so it's really about
getting a group around you have people
that inspire you and can do fantastic
work and that started right back when
Michael and I were writing the script
together like coming up with the ideas
that creative collaboration is the sort
of beginning of all of this and then
we've been lucky enough to be adding
more and more incredible people along
the way that hopefully can help us
create an incredible movie last question
was the best motherly advice that you've
ever received oh wow that's a good one
if you'd motherly advice it was probably
like don't give up you know and that's
been a theme throughout the process of
making this film to like there's been
lots of steps along the way where it
would have been easier to be like I
forget about that forget about this
whole filmmaking gambit that seems a bit
tricky but know if you want something
you just gotta go at it you just gotta
persevere and that's something that you
know my mom has always been in my corner
saying no you just keep going you just
keep going and you win it in the end
Hillary says pretty much the exact same
really yeah she said that that pretty
much something like that last question
so it seemed like there this could be
like an open-world would do you have any
interest in kind of expanding on it from
where we left off at the end without
spoiling anything but I'd love to okay
Michael and I have had conversations
about that like where this story could
go for all okay so it's really about the
reaction that we get from the audience
and how loud they are like if if Netflix
he is loudly you know that there's an
enthusiasm to continue this story like
Michael and I have ideas I'm excited to
hear that Netflix everybody makes sure
to tune in because I'm excited for the
future of this I can't wait for us thank
you for so much for sitting down with us
and I can't wait for everybody to see
this